let me give you some of the ages that we
have in america and what you can do
age like what age you need to be to do
different things you want to be a
president how old do you need to be 35
you're going to be a vp 35 senator
30. congressman 25 we just had the
youngest congressman ever by the way
house of representative i'm sorry 25 we
just had the youngest by the way just so
you know we broke the record
the youngest just won have you seen this
young kid good looking guy have you seen
this kid young kid
type it in youngest house of
representative
uh i think he's 28 maybe 27 type it in
he broke a record
uh no it's not a uh he beat aoc yeah he
beat it
it's a good looking uh uh uh 25 percent
what is north carolina
that's the one 25 years old uh uh right
there the dude in the wheelchair yes
they're doing a wheelchair
youngest 25 year old north carolina
representative republican madison
25 year old congratulations to him in
the wheelchair
to uh uh what's his name i want to give
a proper shout out madison madison
cawthon hawthorne
props to you brother madison cawthorne
if you know him send him this message
uh this video here so 25 years old okay
sexual consent there you go watch this
what did you say what was that first one
sexual connection okay i got you
let's go to sexual consent this is the
one
that fully flabbergasted everybody in
this room okay
out of 50 states when you think about
the right
a to consent age to have sex the legal
age to have sex what number do we think
about
i guess 16 18 something like that i
think about 18. i've never thought
about 16. you guys think about 16 luis
what do you think about 18.
what do you think about it 18 16. so you
think about 16 two both of you are under
16. no no i want to retract that
cut cut 18. 18.
live buddy you're saying 16 now because
you saw the stats at the beginning kai
what do you think about it
in norway it's always been 16. norway's
always been 16. okay so check this out
if you didn't know
now you're gonna know can you pull up
the states on what age you have to be to
have
legal sex without getting rex arrested
check this out she's almost done okay
watch this watch this
go up a little bit all of these states
alabama's 16.
so is alaska arizona's 18 arkansas 16
california 18 colorado 17.
connecticut 60 meaning a 50 year old can
have sex with a 16 year old and you are
not going to get
arrested whoa where are you getting the
50 year old thing
right there in uh what do you call it in
um
closing close in age exception is that
exemption is that
exemption yes exemption colorado 17
connecticut 16 delaware 18 dc
16 dc all the politicians 16.
uh florida 18. good for you guys florida
does it right 18
georgia 16 hawaii 16 idaho 18 illinois
17 indiana 16 iowa 16
kansas 16 kentucky 16 louisville are you
noticing
80 percent is 16 main 16 maryland 16
massachusetts michigan
minnesota 16 missouri 17 montana
nebraska nevada 16. new hampshire 16
jersey 16
new mexico new york 17 carolina 16
dakota
18. ohio oklahoma 16 oregon 18. i would
think oregon would have been like 15.
pennsylvania 16 rhode island 16.
south carolina dakota 16 tennessee 18.
good for them texas 17. oh nice
utah 18 vermont 16 virginia 18
washington 16
west virginia 16 wisconsin 18 wyoming 7.
interesting here west virginia 16 but 15
if it's your sister so way to go
if it's your sister okay so so the legal
age to have sex
eighty percent the states is 16. some of
the other ones
is 18. okay next criminal
responsibility okay criminal
responsibility state by state
33 states set no minimum age of criminal
criminal responsibility for federal
crimes the minimum age of criminal
responsibility is 11.
driving 14 to 16 years old you can drive
with a permit
16 to 17 restricted license
18 unrestricted which by the way you
said it earlier today
can you are you comfortable with 16 year
olds driving a car i don't know i know
what i did the moment i passed my
driver's license i know exactly what i
did that minute
yeah when i got the car when i think of
how difficult it is to drive and
everything you have to know 16 is too
young okay
so that can be debated but it's 16
gambling 21
drinking 21. working 16-17
marriage 18. nebraska is 19
mississippi's 21 meaning in mississippi
you can't be married
21 years old yeah mississippi nebraska's
19th we're learning stuff
retirement 62 to 67. leaving school
16 to 19 you can choose to leave i don't
want to go to school anymore mom i'm
dropping out
smoking they changed it eric was
devastated smoking
21 cigarettes and wheat is 21. you ready
voting is what 18. let me get this
straight
you mean to tell me i'm not allowed to
drink until i'm 21 years old
i am not allowed to smoke wheat or
cigarettes till i'm 21 years old
i'm not allowed i'm not allowed to
gamble until i'm 21 years old
but i'm allowed to vote at 18. or you're
allowed to die for your country
and serve in the army or the military
it's absolutely pathetic to me
if you think about it it's absolutely
pathetic to me when you think about i
think the voting system
needs to be changed my opinion i've been
saying this for a long time